there's one major source of illness and
i'm talking about any kind of illness uh
whether that's so-called mental illness
or uh physical illness
and that's childhood trauma
and this is through whether i'm talking
about anxiety depression adhd addiction
psychosis
um
bipolar illness
or if i'm talking about multiple
sclerosis cancer rheumatoid arthritis
fibromyalgia
chronic fatigue
colitis crohn's disease
als
scleroderma
and as i said malignancy as well and
that seems like a very
bold statement
but
today i'll be concentrating on the
physical side of it when i say physical
side i'm talking about the illnesses
that are not considered to be mental
illnesses
um as a matter of fact what i'll be
telling you and i just i'm just giving
you a a preview of what i'll be saying
is that um
and it's quite okay i wish you would
argue with me uh both in your mind and
also verbally uh
that's the way we get through to the
heart of things i'll be saying you to
you that just about everything
not everything but just about everything
that we call illness
begins is rooted in compensations and
adaptations that have to do with
childhood trauma
and
i'll quote you
something to that
effect just to prove that i'm not
totally crazy
or
if i am crazy i'm not alone in my
craziness
this is from the journal pediatrics
which is the official journal of the
american academy of pediatrics and the
article appeared in
their journal
six years ago now
in february the
february of 2012.
and the article is from the harvard
center on a developing child
and here's what they say in their
abstract
growing scientific evidence demonstrates
that social and physical environments
that threaten human development because
of scarcity
stress or instability
can lead to short-term physiologic and
psychological adjustments that are
necessary for immediate survival and
adaptation
but you may come but which may come at a
significant cost
um
to long-term outcomes in learning
behavior health and longevity
and it words what they're saying is that
the adaptations that
children are forced to
resort to
in response to early stress help them
endure
that early duress and difficulty but
those same adaptations become source of
pathology later on and even threaten
longevity
now that article came out just six years
ago um
but that's the perspective that i came
to
adopt or or or understand
a long time ago
in medical practice
in order to understand the
basis of that we have to consider how we
look at human beings so and how we look
at disease
now western medicine looks at disease
from a particular perspective and you
have to understand something about
medicine it's science all right but it's
also ideology and there's a difference
in science and ideology there's a lot of
science in it and it's great science but
there's also ideology and ideology is a
point of view it's it's it's a
the german state it's a walton shang
it's it's it's a
world view
that you're not conscious of
that that you have hidden beliefs that
you don't question
and people that question the hidden
beliefs
are seen as outliers or mavericks
and that's an ideology
that exists in all realms
whether politics or or science
or medicine or or
history
or economics or any field of
human thought or investigation
so there's always ideological biases
hidden in any system
and
the logic of the system
operates within those biases now what
are the biases of western medicine well
the bias of western medicine
and any of your medical colleagues here
want to disagree with me i'll be happy
to although i doubt that you will
because i just think that if you're
doing psychotherapy you'll probably
agree with me already
but uh
but maybe not
but the hidden biases are number one
that diseases
have either
physical causes
in the sense of genes or external
forces like bacteria or viruses or
toxins
or we don't know what the causes are
so the causes are either physical or the
disease is what we call idiopathic we
don't know what the source of it is so
that's one bias is that causes are
purely physical
the second bias
is that
diseases happen to organs
so you have heart disease and you have
lung disease and you have
diseases of connective tissue or the
liver or whatever
and then there's specialties designated
to study in depth the diseases of these
organs
but
but that
except for obvious
lifestyle so-called lifestyle
[Music]
proclivity is like smoking or drinking
we don't really think that the life of
an individual is a whole lot to do with
the disease of the organ
so you know cancer strikes somebody who
doesn't smoke
we don't know what causes it
so we separate the organ from the the
whole person
and then we separate the person from
the environment so that the social
environment we might acknowledge the
role of the physical environment but
certainly not acknowledge the law of the
social environment
so
in western medical terms
the average physician would not be able
to explain to you
and this is not for lack of intelligence
simply for lack of training
i would not be able to explain to you
why is it that the more episodes of
racism a black american woman
experiences the greater her risk for
asthma
it's just a documented
fact nor would the average physician be
able to tell you very easily
the
multiple times documented fact that
children whose parents are stressed are
more likely to have asthma as a matter
of fact the degree of the child's asthma
has been correlated with the degree of
mental disturbance on the part of the
parent
so
you go to the physician you get the
inhalers but that's all that happens
and so
norwood
let me just give you another fact which
i'll won't explain now but a study in
australia looked at 500 women with
breast biopsies who were suspicious or
at least um a concern enough was raised
that it should be malignancy or not so
they had these biopsies and they also
had a psychological evaluation and the
results came back and turned out that if
a woman
was stretched that by itself did not
increase the risk of that lumping cancer
so there was zero effect and similarly
if a woman
uh was emotionally isolated that by
itself also did not increase the chances
of the love being canceled zero effect
but if a woman was stressed and isolated
the risk of that love being cancerous
was nine times as great as the average
and the researchers being scientists
and medical scientists couldn't explain
this one because they said it's strange
how does zero and zero add up to nine
well
that becomes clear
how zero and zero add up to nine becomes
very clear if you understand that human
beings can't be separated from the
environment
and what happens inside an individual on
a physiological level is very much uh
determined or at least
affected by
what happens to them on the social level
so uh
nor would
the average physician be able to explain
to you based on their training
why is it that if you look at lung
cancer
the more adverse childhood experiences
that you have
in other words the more trauma you've
experienced the greater your risk of
lung cancer and this is true even if you
cancel out smoking as a factor
nor nor would the average physician be
able to say a whole lot about the fact
that a canadian study showed that
if you were abused as a child your risk
of cancer goes up by nearly 50 percent
and this is even after you've
factored in or factored out things like
smoking and drinking which abused people
are more likely to do
so these are the questions that we have
to be able to answer and it seems to me
that that any one of these facts that i
just told you which are not in question
ought to stand the whole profession
running to figure out the what's going
on in the correlation to physiology and
emotions and our social existence but we
don't do that because we exclude this
kind of information that's the
ideological bias
and so
70 years ago this year there was a
physician
called george engel
who called for a different model of
medicine
and
he said
as soon as he says
that the dominant model of medicine
today talking almost half a century ago
is biomedical with molecular biology
it's basic scientific discipline
it assumes disease to be fully accounted
for by deviations from the norm of
measurable
biological somatic variables it leaves
no room within its framework for the
social psychological and behavioral
dimensions of illness
the biomedical model embraces mind-body
dualism the doctrine that separates the
mental from the somatic
and
dr neumann deutsch who's a well-known
psychiatrist here in toronto writes on
brain plasticity he wrote similarly
just last year
modern scientific medicine has taken a
fundamentally materialistic approach and
it is analytical meaning that it divides
holes into parts
it often proceeds by reducing complex
phenomena to their more elementary
chemical
and physical components
viruses
genes
and molecules
so things haven't changed much since
george angle wrote those words
and
what he called for
was a
biopsychosocial approach
which meant that the biology of human
beings cannot be separated
from their
psychological and social environments
now
at the same time
human beings have always known we've
always known that things can't be
separated so there's there's always been
this
tussle you might say between a unitary
holistic view of human beings
and and existence in general and the
dualistic you that separates things
so the buddha said 2500 years ago he
says contemplate the in the
interconnected core rising of all
phenomena that's what he called it the
interconnected core rising of phenomena
he said look at her leave for a raindrop
he says and meditate
he says meditate in all the conditions
that are necessary for the existence of
the leaf or rain drop
so obviously i mean
trivially obvious you look at a a
leaf it contains the sun
the light the photosynthesis
it contains the earth in the form of
minerals and it contains the sky in
front of the water
so that the leaf literally contains
earth's sun and sky
and he says he says
the birth of any phenomenon he says is
is dependent on the birth of other
phenomena he says without the many that
cannot be the one without the one that
cannot be the many
and that was the border 2500 years ago
and
the
wonderful writer um susan griffin in her
really transcendent book the course of
stones
wrote that
the story of one life cannot be told
separately from the story of other lives
who are we the question is not simple
what we call the self is part of a
larger matrix of relationships and
society
all the lives that surround us are in us
[Music]
you